well joining me now is stephen kinnick
the shadow minister for immigration good
to talk to you this morning uh mr clinic
do you think ukraine can win this on its
own
i think that president putin has made a
massive strategic miscalculation
you cannot with an army of 150 000 hope
to occupy an entire country of 44
million people where everybody hates you
and at the most they may try to hold
kievan kharkiv but the rest of the
country will resist they will fight the
resistance the courage the determination
of the ukrainian people is an
inspiration to us all and mr putin has
clearly bitten off more than he can chew
and the key now will be to resist uh
push him back
and i am absolutely convinced that the
russians will be defeated in this war
they will be expelled from ukraine and
ukraine will return to being a free
democratic and sovereign country
but at what cost and how long would that
potentially take
well uh what we know in russia is that
there are people around vladimir putin
of course who are deeply corrupt
and very bad people but they also have a
very strong desire for self-preservation
and at some point they will realize that
their self-preservation depends more on
getting rid of mr putin than on him
continuing and as uh more and more
russian soldiers are dying in the field
as there is less and less understanding
in russia as to why they are waging this
war mr putin's position will become
increasingly
shaky what we will also see is
hugely increased isolation in terms of
the russian economy that really is
already beginning to bite we're seeing
massive inflation
and weakening of the ruble
and a huge increase in interest rates
this is all starting to affect the
oligarchs and the kleptocrats that prop
mr putin up and that's the key is to
make the russian elite realize military
and security and political elites
realize uh that they are backing the
wrong horse here
and that that has to change and that i
think is going to be very important for
the west to stand together very strongly
in that we've been too naive and too
complacent in the west for too long the
conservative governments in this country
since 2010 have rolled out the red
carpet for authoritarian regimes uh like
china they've allowed russia they've
allowed london to become
awash with
dirty russian money
and we need to see all of that changing
now we need to see a reform of companies
house we need to see a proper
overseas
entities bill so that we can see who
actually owns these assets we need to
see the sanctions that are being carried
out against russian oligarchs be working
far more quickly uh the asset
freezes are too slow and there's a real
risk of asset flight as a lot of these
oligarchs will just start to sell up all
their assets
and that will not be achieving the
objectives that we've set out so
you know we're moving in the right
direction but it's been too slow this is
a huge reality check i think for our
country and for the whole of europe
we've got to rise to this challenge
because our values democracy and freedom
are on the line
do you think those sanctions should
extend to roman abramovich
yes absolutely uh there is a list very
clearly
list of of names that's been published
for example
by alexey navalny the opposition leader
uh in uh in russia it includes people
like abramovic
like usmanov
we've seen the european union and
the united states publishing those names
i am just mystified as to why the
british government is not publishing the
names of the people that we are
sanctioning and getting on with the job
it's too slow uh it's it just looks like
foot dragging there's arguments about
the legal side of it but the
government's got to step up and show the
leadership that we must show
just to reflect the tremendous courage
and leadership that the ukrainian people
are showing it is the very least that we
can do for them
and we've got to move forward
more quickly those asset
freezes need to be put in place very
very quickly
and this is personal for you isn't it
you used to live in russia you worked in
saint petersburg with the british ancel
you were arrested while you were out
there how do you personally view what
what putin is doing
well
my memory from russia is just the
enormous gap that there is between the
russian people and their leadership the
russian people want to live normal lives
they want to be a normal country that is
connected to the rest of the world there
are a strong and resilient people but
they're so badly led they are led by
deeply corrupt thugs and gangsters who
are
letting russia down and are only
interested in holding on to power and
lining their own pockets
so it always made me very sad when i was
in russia to see that and and of course
we in the end in the british council we
we stood up to the russians uh they they
sought to close down our our operations
and and we stood up to mr putin because
we knew that uh the the values that we
hold dear and our desire
for
building better relationships between
the british people and the russian
people that was more important than
dancing to mr putin's tune
and that i think is what we have to take
away from this is that the bullies only
understand the language of strength and
unity and consistency
and the moment that they
smell weakness they will exploit that
and they will go for you so you have to
be ready to to push back we need to
build our resilience uh as a country
against these authoritarian regimes that
are seeking to undermine our democracy
because you can't go out and project
strength in the world until you get your
own house in order uh back at home so
we've got to learn those lessons
russia and the russian people
it's a great country and a great people
but
these corrupt
dictators
are badly letting them down we have to
stand up against that
and we have to do it in a way that is
united and strong with our
democratic allies and partners